What if all the travelers could discuss, invite, exchange views...
...and finalize the trip on one common platform?
Now, JustOrbit is here!
Do everything under one roof.
Find the destinations you wish to visit.
Find the perfect destination.
Add and remove cities to visit with just a click.
Find and add attractions and activities to your itinerary.
Include all the local activities which you would like to explore.
Save the trip and easily share all the details with whoever you want.
The benefits of planning your trip with JustOrbit include:...
...all invited members receive an email with all the trip details.
All trip plans come with an authentication code.
Simply click, enter the code and start discussing.
Once a member is satisfied with the plans, they can request trip finalization,...
...followed by the creator, putting a freeze on the trip.
The next step is booking hotels and attractions.
Plus, there is a variety of suggested tour packages based on your plans...
...to make it even easier.
Bookings done, now it's time to travel.
Travel planning is easy with JustOrbit.com.